Do you know what it feels like?
It's like... I've woken up
in someone else's life.
Surface is a thriller about identity
and about uncovering
the truth about yourself.
Who you were, who you are,
and who you really wanna be.
Sophie had a traumatic brain injury,
and it's really her putting the pieces
of her life back together.
So she wakes up in this perfect life,
but something, at the core,
she knows is wrong.
If my life was so perfect...
why did I try to end it?
So this question is eating at her
from the beginning of the series.
Everything starts to crack
and starts to sort of shake and change.
All these characters
are kind of playing two sides.
There's the version
that the audience knows,
and then there's the real version.
For Sophie, this duality of...
Is she actually who everybody
thinks she is?
And is she a good person?
And is she capable of bad things?
...is really interesting.
Hey, let me take that.
James is madly in love with Sophie
and would do anything for her.
But as time goes on, Sophie starts
to question his authenticity.
Baden's definitely a guy
who's a little bit mysterious.
Why did you say that about my husband?
It's usually the person who's closest
to the victim that's responsible.
But I'm not a victim.
That's only because you survived.
Duality of purpose, duality of motive,
is something that's constantly explored.
It's all about the double meanings
and what lies beneath.
You'll be constantly guessing
which person you should be rooting for.
Every single episode,
cards are turned over,
and the unexpected becomes the reality.